oh this this oh yeah we're gonna love
this so this is the kid yeah that I did
the video about his ticked is tick-tock
like self tape auditions they does what
is the boy yeah Tyler this is the boy
and so he dropped it he dropped a new
heater on us and this one's World War 3
themed World War 3 themed naturally I
mean as as you do yes everyone's talking
about right now so you know that's what
art is about it's it's about you know
providing commentary on and and shedding
light I guess on other sides of certain
issues or you know making people think a
different way from what they normally
think about things that are trending so
Tyler here provides his commentary on
World War 3 I almost think that he's
[ __ ] with with us at this point I
really do because this one he goes he go
this just watch it it felt like a bit he
goes hard I need to talk to you
first things first here's the carnations
your favorite flower flower flower
flower cuz carnations is a favorite
flower
yeah I wanted I want to go on tick-tock
and be like just do the exact dialogue I
brought these for you
it's your favorite flower a carnation I
have a draft letter as well it's like in
between Arnold and [ __ ] and so that's
all I know Sylvester is easy yeah
sending me to World War 3 - World War
first of all he says is she like he's
gonna vomit like it doesn't even seem
like crime
[Music]
smelling World War three sent me to work
with theirs sent me
[Music]
Oh miss
leopard shirt dog the earrings like
first of all he's dressed like he's
dressed like Jota right now he should be
on the Kathie Lee show this [ __ ] -
he's acting like he ate like the last
dab on hot wings rubbing his eyes and
like clinching his oh god [ __ ] you Sean
I'm gonna World War three dude imagine I
just imagine like Ebola drafted for the
war Oh bro beer out what [ __ ] dude this
[ __ ] sucks [ __ ] sucks dude I got
drafted for World War three they're
sending me to a [ __ ] World War 3 it's
so wack you know they've just [ __ ] wine
that [ __ ] all the way up until boot camp
oh yeah definitely yeah I got drafted
better send me nudes now before it's too
late
yeah you might want to [ __ ] a future war
hero Oh God
that made me feel bad you don't want to
miss out yeah purple hearts he's under
perfect because you know I'm gonna war
saying your Purple Hearts because you
know I'm a bat
I love [ __ ] that's why I'm a vet
well damn guess I'm leaving tomorrow
[ __ ]
straight to Iran I'll call you I ran
I'll never run from you you should be I
ran cuz you got I ran and all around my
brain for you damn they said I can't
wear these cross earrings to the war two
World War three
imagine dude imagine all getting the
[ __ ] military cut no did way dude
it's super house war it's wacky it's
super hard to center part my hair just
they grow a little one down the middle
that's the military boy cut it's just a
faint [ __ ] hair split down the middle
it's like a budding mohawk and they just
push it to the head yeah I do shit's
[ __ ] just [ __ ] up drill sergeant on
my ass bro well let me keep my [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] cross earring dawg
they just yanked that [ __ ] out yeah give
me 20 I mean bro people in the military
be making trailers and [ __ ] so they're
not told that's true I guess we're not
that far off not that far off man
alright keep going with this
[Music]
I'm a soldier now this part I shouldn't
cry I'll see you in six months
yeah this problem on dude I love you
babe I'm coming back for you
that's we're so so disrespectful that's
where it feels like a bit like it has to
be a bit yeah the part where he puts on
a skateboard helmet has to be a bit yeah
yeah and then he yeah
- attention true so wait you're leaving
now
right now mmm - attention here's the
thing bro so I look at this I like and I
talk about this a little bit on stream
last night but you know like you know
when you have a flashback - what the
[ __ ] you know when you have a flashback
- like doing something embarrassing and
it could be something minor maybe
personal you ever get one of those like
maybe something reminds you something
you oh god I used to do blah blah blah
you know I used to be into that I used
to wear those clothes or whatever like
as it easy example right yeah you
looking like some I don't know some
shitty haircut yeah yeah oh my ears be
[ __ ] yeah and you have like that
little moment over you're like [ __ ] yeah
let's take it off huh whatever he's
that's this for this kid when he's like
25 you know collecting some [ __ ] at a
printer at his [ __ ] desk job is
someone's gonna be like ever gonna World
War 4 and he's like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah well the problem is now it's
like immortalized forever
yeah in so many different ways yeah
going into the job interview was Tyler
[ __ ] wait a minute hold on Tyler yep
yeah yeah that's me yeah that was me
oh oh we're out of here yeah just get
drafted I thought you went to war is
your helmet the problem like what I'm
saying is like even if tik-tok dies this
video will forever live on duck yeah
doctor fan account Twitter account like
ever like there's so many duplications
now and it's crazy
now I dude it's gonna be there it'll be
on i funny i funny too yeah i 43 oh yeah
[ __ ] four just i funny 180 180 p meme
account just all the time yeah yeah
compress sixty times and he'll try to
you know he's gonna try to move on to do
some respectable it's the same [ __ ] you
know first can ya like wait a minute
this is you and it's just three pixels
but you can see somebody doing this he's
like god dammit yeah that's me that's me
brother
you